[Music]
foreign
cruise and Nicole Kidman's son Connor
posts a rare photo playing golf your
children will have such a different life
than than say you did or most children
what do you do to try to make it as
normal as possible I don't know what
normal is everyone there's everybody is
unique and they have their own story to
tell
so I you know we just give him lots of
love you know do just do the best we can
so farther I can you know they're very
very happy the 28 year old shared this
snap over the weekend at the Pelican
Golf Club in Bel Air Florida that's
Connor posing in a striped polo shirt
gray shorts Shades and a hat flashing a
thumbs up next to his friend on the
green as a parent what you hope for that
they find things that they're interested
in the post marks his first since August
2022 and while he's mostly stayed out of
the spotlight in recent years he did
attend the diesel fashion show for Milan
Fashion Week in February wow a big wow
Tom and Nicole adopted both Connor and
his older sister Bella when they were
still married you've got the two
children you ever think about expanding
the family who knows what's going to
happen in the future I'm not going to
say we won't I'm not gonna
we will the two tied the knot in 1990.
your time with your family and time to
refuel and then we make sure we take
that time they called it quits in 2001
and in 2018 Nicole explained why she's
so private when it comes to the children
she shares with her ex telling
Australia's who magazine she has to
protect them and she would give up her
life for her children because it's her
purpose as for how she feels about them
choosing to be scientologists like their
father she told the mag they are adults
who are able to make their own decisions
they have made choices to be
scientologists and as a mother it's my
job to love them no matter what your
child does the child has love and the
child has to know there is available
love and I'm open here I think when you
raise children it's the it's just the
greatest gift to be able to
to be there for them and to to watch
them of course Tom also shares a 17 year
old daughter Suri with his ex-wife Katie
Holmes is just a real light and very
happy very very happy and very joyous
child and Nicole is also a mom to 14
year old daughter Sunday and 12 year old
daughter Faith with husband Keith Urban
I think the greatest thing when you're I
think when you're just a really close
family and while Nicole has stayed
pretty tight-lipped about her older
kiddos she praised Bella's creativity to
E.T back in 2018. Bella is a beautiful
drawer as well she's always been able to
draw and in 2015 she told women's weekly
Bella and Connor are generous kind and
hard-working adding these are traits
that I love to see in my children
[Music]
thank you